it's not the internet that's coming the
newspaper it's that newspapers are
trying too hard to hold on to a past the
problem here is that there are new
opportunities newspapers have not seen
what they're seeing instead is fear of
change every other industry in this
country in this world has to change
because the Internet
why shouldn't newspapers other
industries that are smart are embracing
this change and newspapers are out of
fear only beginning to it's doesn't make
any difference to me whether or not the
printing press can he use as long as the
journalist movie news I met a love Russ
Berger the editor of The Guardian long
ago and they had just spent 150 million
dollars on new presses and he said very
calmly oh yes those are probably the
last presses will ever buy now I can
imagine an American publisher would say
that and keel over at that moment but
Russ Berger realizes that what he's
continuing is the journalism and he's
got to find ways to make a continue in
this new world it's not gonna be the
same as it was the newspapers were
one-size-fits-all monopolies those days
are over the business has changed the
scale of the business has changed but if
they start thinking more collaboratively
if they start thinking more flexibly I
think journalism can actually grow
if I were in the New York Times company
today I would use the Boston Globe as a
laboratory to do all kinds of new and
brave things and figure out what to do
maybe it shouldn't be in print maybe it
should go hyperlocal
maybe it should go multimedia maybe it
should be five different products I
don't know but I would try them out in
Boston at the New York Times itself
their strength is their weakness because
they are this incredible institution and
they're trying to protect that and for
good reason but that protectionism is
not a strategy for the future and then
they realize that I'm not saying
anything to them they don't know they
are trying to do new things but they're
constantly saddled with being the New
York Times so what I hope really happens
is that in newspapers across the country
will see experiments about new ways to
do things
the Madison Capitol Times an afternoon
paper in a two paper market has just
gone out of print except for a to once a
week supplements and they're now going
to go solely online we'll see how that
works I think every paper the country
should be looking at new experiments and
seeing new ways to do things